coming up next but I just started doing
this last price so I'm like I don't know
if I can get it in 15 minutes 15 minutes
but men are not supposed to be
suffocated by a woman that can't handle
being alive if you can't be in a
relationship and you can't see a future
don't be in it don't waste your time
don't waste your body don't waste your
energy don't waste your brain and don't
waste his time either you look back and
you say that you you lost is it but yes
or no nothing's complicated or situation
[__] some type of situation ships
complicated no are you in a relationship
yes or no okay so the only way you don't
lose someone is kind of if you kind of
go who understand that relationship I'm
not saying that's the that applies to me
right now they're like what do you love
about the 60s I'm like
[Laughter]
if you want to come on an episode of
wife school yeah yeah wow we have so
many applicants here life is cool what
why school oh yeah we do um it's just
like wife classes basically so things
we're basically training pool we were
training up Pearl to be wifey material
she's getting there and he didn't think
I was wife
[Laughter]
besides that she wants everybody else to
come in because I think she's feeling a
bit um
I needed the bread well yeah okay the
bread what did you have to change
everything what have you had to change
since white school
um okay we have we have different
chapters okay this chapter I'm in is
cooking okay so I'm really trying to be
able to cook healthy food for a family
so
um I've been feeding my staff
blessing blessings
look yeah in the beginning I had some
mess-ups I won't lie but I've actually
improved a lot in the last like about
13. if you can cook can I just ask a
question can I ask everybody what's
their um their favorite meal to cook
what meal if you had 15 minutes to cook
what would you cook 15 minutes one five
one five fifteen what would you cook off
the top of your head what kind of pasta
and what oh about Bolognese okay what
would you cook steak damn you took mine
like chicken pasta with some cream
cheese something like that okay what
would you cook young lady just 15
minutes yeah oh my partner likes corn
beef fashion beetroot so it's pretty
easy okay and it's literally
steak and eggs okay steak in 15 minutes
it takes me six minutes to cook my steak
you have yours no is there you have a
blue it's even less right I like it I do
like it blue I really like it blue
sometimes I like mine pink
so what would you cook young lady
um I oh sorry I probably make fried rice
in 15 minutes that's probably what I can
make with a bit of chicken in it
vegetables peas
okay I would do okay I'm turning I
either want to do the sushi bowl or the
July fries but I just started doing the
jollof rice so I'm like I don't know if
I can get it in 15 minutes 15 minutes
you could cook jollof rice
I'm trying to teach you how to do it TV
you can do it in the rice cooker 15
minutes nothing not the real one I've
done the railway that takes a lot longer
what is your favorite thing to make
cookies
I have a family like recipe that my
grandma tell my mom my mom taught me and
it's like cookies from scratch I like
that I'm a really big dessert person
it's not good
um but Auntie also just taught me a cake
that I really like making too it's not
so the things that are not good for her
yeah oh yeah tell me about it I had to
stop baking when I started losing weight
it was like well I can make a Victoria
sponge or I can lose no weight so it's
gonna be one of the other yeah I've had
the same realization recently yeah when
you get when you get a text at two
o'clock in the morning where are the
cookies there's no sugar in the house
but take care of that and then the next
episode uh or next month what are we
doing fashion we're doing fashion yeah
and then the month because I've always
been a tomboy so I've always really like
I've just been such a Tumblr I've just
never keep wearing it just right now I
know it's big for me
because a year ago I was in sweats every
time
that day when I cut your dresses up oh
yeah yeah and he like
um she cut my jeans because yeah because
she felt like they were ugly I'm pretty
late I'm pretty laid back How's that
gonna go ahead
they're really nice shorts
um and then after that what are we doing
etiquette yeah etiquette and then
that's gonna be honest
um and then dance and then I don't know
what oh wow dance as well yeah are you
teaching dance no we're probably getting
it
good question
like an instructor or something
she's been at dancing already but she
won't post it
she went 60s Go-Go dancing
into a class oh I'm sure you do
I've set her up I said this to a dance
class when she got there she realized
what it was for yeah love that no I
didn't know what go go dancing it was
like a whole Community they're like
obsessed with the 60s yeah and I was
like they're like what do you love about
the 60s I'm like
[Laughter]
Us in there I guess I guess this class
uh no they were young actually most
people I would say were like 20s and 30s
there's like only one or two older
ladies wow yeah yeah they're mostly
anyone else taken an owl anyone else in
relationships yeah like a tooth that was
the Ella took from the relationship
[Laughter]
you look back and you say that you you
lost
like you were not the winner you were
the loser
I think I've dumped every man that I've
ever been with and I've always won I'm
glad
yeah
that's good no one else
really wow
so I don't feel like I've lost in a
relationship I mean you're only 19. yeah
but yeah I don't yeah the thing is I
don't have too much to lose right do you
get it like other than emotional damage
drama probably like daily routine I
don't really have much to lose compared
to other people like money's not
involved in it family's not involved in
it friends barely you know
so to be fair I don't feel like I've
lost in a relationship why do you have a
relationship why do you what is it about
relationship why do you go into
relationship at such a young age
um I think I like having
someone there that I can confide in but
yeah teddy bear
[Music]
um I think mostly because
I like someone that can add on to my
lifestyle I like someone that I can at
the end of the day go back and be like
this is like this is my person kind of
like my best friend
um how's it working for you great
are you in a relationship now is it's
complicated but that's still great that
means no is it a yes or no nothing's
complicated or situation [__] some type
of situation ships complicated no are
you in relationship yes or no okay I am
not in a relationship I am in a I am in
a partnership which we're still figuring
stuff out um I recently just tried to
cut cut him off
no
um so I think it was more so we kind of
went cool like this is why I saw maybe
it was a bit of a hasty decision so we
can stay in until we try to figure out
what's up and if it's not meant to be
it's not meant to be but yeah that's a
lot for such a young age
yeah I feel like a lot of younger
generation feel like they need to be in
a relationship
um I've got two girls
um and my youngest feels like she needs
to be in a relationship and I don't I
don't get it but and where my job and
what I I work with children
a lot of young teenagers and adolescents
feel like they need
to be in a relationship it's quite scary
I think I think more so than being in a
relationship I think it's more so that
you don't want to lose that person so
the only way you don't lose someone
else you kind of go could I understand
that relationship I'm not saying that's
that applies to me right now but that's
kind of like
well I think the general mindset is can
I give you a bit of advice my mom always
said to me um you know you said you
always want somebody to be there you
don't want to be on your own yeah my mom
would say you're not a twin yeah 100 so
if you're not a twin you should be used
to being on your own only twins need
somebody that will miss someone so get
over your loneliness and get out there
and get a hobby and stop being a man I
will admit that I could I do struggle to
be alone I will openly admit that and I
think more times right now I've
practiced being alone I think I don't
need that validation from someone else
to be like I can do this I can do that
but do you know I think that's a big
responsibility to put on somebody else
to not make you feel alone and to bring
you that kind of Happiness inside not
because I would never be like I would
never approach someone and be like yeah
like I need you to be there for me it's
just kind of what happens I don't end up
I don't think women are meant to be
alone
like I mean I I can understand like a
teenager you might not want them getting
in a relationship but it's it feels
really good being single I mean I mean
in the short term but I mean we've more
women on antidepressants than ever
before and we're more single than ever
before I agree with you I don't think
sorry I don't think women
are supposed to be alone
but men are not supposed to be
suffocated by a woman that can't handle
being alert
um and I think that's the difference
until you're with someone be happy being
alone yeah and if you're not happy being
alone then the person that you're going
to be if you're going to suffocate hell
out of him 100 yeah I wonder 100 but
yeah she was the man and she's going to
be with him then just leave the man
rather than going back with him 100 no
because I agree with you no I'm I'm not
gonna sit here and lie to you and say
I've been ignorant to everything I'll be
real like I'm a kind of person I have to
think everything through believe it or
not so if I'm gonna stay in something I
know why I'm gonna stay in it because it
works for me and it works for both of us
somewhat but it's also the um also at a
point where it's kind of like cool I can
do whatever I want right now this is the
time for me to learn it's a time for me
to do whatever I want to do and you know
something right I think that's the worst
thing that mother people say nowadays
you think so is that Now's the Time
because I'm sure that all the older
people I'm saying oh they're not like me
older I wish they didn't do that no if
you if you can be if you you're sensible
or you sound sensible if you're sensible
now stop going in stupid relationships
sort yourself out and get in one that
works because you're talking with a lot
of sense so you know what works so you
know that don't work you know
stop picking up crap pick up something
that you can study and I'm sure when you
keep on thinking a lot of you like oh
yeah that's what we need now but you can
if she had a way again she'd do it
differently if she was 18 or 19 we all
will and that's what I find that when
you get young people they don't think
they don't take advice from older people
because she just said why do they need
to be in a relationship there's no
reason for you to be in a relationship
unless you're gonna deal in a
relationship to be serious to get
married or something like that because
if I was young now I think I'd be
married at 19 or 20 and I think I'd be a
virgin until I was 19 or 20 knowing what
I know now
and I'm sure that anybody else who's
done it but everybody's not in
everybody's nodding so if you can't be
in a relationship and you can't see a
future don't be in it don't waste your
time don't waste your body don't waste
your energy don't waste your brain and
don't waste his time either
because you might get back together oh
once I'm getting what I know what stuck
out when you said somewhat we're getting
what we want somewhat that means that
you're not you're just hanging on in
there until something better comes along
until you get bored and dump him get out
of it um foreign
[Laughter]
antidepressants so in my work what I
find is that it's people are living
unnaturally people are stuck on their
phones people eating the wrong diet a
lot of processed food a lot of junk and
that actually is a causal
um contributor to depression so I find
people that come to me for coaching and
I found with myself once I changed my
diet my depression my anxiety completely
went and I was in the same situation so
it was nothing to do with being in a
relationship not being in a relationship
um who was around me it was me and the
food that I was eating the inflammation
I was causing within my body and then
stopping that sorry go ahead and sort of
reverse in that and then not having to
deal with that no any longer no I think
that's a good point I definitely think
diet is a part of it do you you
typically think women that are 50 child
childless and single are typically happy
no no and I think that that's part of
the agenda feminist the gender isn't it
and the agenda was put in place
apparently so that they could then start
taxing
women as well instead of just taxing the
man they now have a household where they
can tax two people two people were
working they make life a bit harder it
makes it harder for the family to stay
together the family's not staying
together you weaken Society we weaken
Society you can control Society you can
control the population so why don't you
eat vegetables because they're they
cause inflammation
don't stop
especially especially the green leafy
ones don't stop especially because so
they have they have anti-nutrients okay
multiple anti-nutrients one of the worst
is oxalates and you'll find that in
spinach you'll find that in almonds
you'll find that in many plant foods and
actually that's so bad too yeah um so if
you if you're thinking of not having
arthritis you want to avoid those what's
wrong with the air fryer no off fries
some things are produced like uric acid
like stiffness
[Laughter]
so vegetables are better this is good so
can I excuse me I'm young lady do you
believe what would you rather
take 10 pills a day that somebody's
giving you to say these are what you
need or eat a veg
I would eat meat and not take no I mean
if you had to eat veg or take these all
these tablets
what do you what do you eat in a day can
I have like a you like steak and eggs
for and I'll let you have steak do you
really want to hear it you're probably
gonna be shocked okay go ahead so for
breakfast I regularly have 10 eggs 10
eggs and I started boiling them because
there's no mess they come out perfect
and they're soft in the middle
um for lunch I might have 10 eggs again
or I might have some sort of
burger patty I eat a lot steak
um chicken chicken fries sometimes I
don't ever go for chicken breasts
because that's just dry and disgusting
it right no wrap it in bacon wrap it in
streaky bacon yeah it's still dry once
you go once you've got no once you go
all red meat it's different
because I'm just I'm struggling to wrap
my head around no vegetables because
then as an athlete I'd kind of have to
oh yeah so you'd do better you think so
yeah I know because I'm kind of like how
does that work so I work for a doctor
who is 56. he is he lives in America and
he is world champion at Rowan at 56. he
has improved his strength and he's been
Carnival seven years
um and he has improved everything he got
rid of all of his illnesses wasn't it I
mean for that diet that came up years
ago that used to be called zero carb
then it went to carnivore diet
um but you know it's just I mean before
that I'm sure there was somebody that
just say it will meet there was a diet
going around years ago oh yeah it's
called um the lion diet oh and the lion
diet yeah
do you mean Primal no
I can't remember what it was but this
guy was just eating me on there it was
just slapping up the meat front it was
just awesome I like him
guy liver oh liver King yeah he lied
though didn't he he lied a lot wait so
10 eggs then 10 eggs again maybe the
mistake do you know what I can
understand the state where the hell do
you put 10 eggs I can't eat two eggs
really no yeah well you eat you eat to
what your what you need nutrition you're
talking boiled yeah I can manage one
do your kids eat only meat too I would
love them too but no they have varied
diet they do but they don't actually
want veggie such they like fruit
and I don't matter so there's some
stories so when they were younger I used
to make them eat their veg and um they
come up with some really good ideas of
how to hide their Vegeta sometimes they
quickly open a window and hide it in the
barbecue or or they'd quickly put it
under the table and then I would
um assume it was the wrong child and
make the other child pick it up and eat
it
and the other one just let them do it
yeah so now they're thankful they're
like yeah so it's eggs
a lot of eggs chicken a lot of red meat
lamb is my favorite wow the Lamb's
expensive right now you should you would
love it in Morocco venison the other day
all right sorry
there's a local there's a local Hunter
who actually
um so you know there's a vegan argument
that actually is wrong to kill animals
well I have someone who is a hunter
that's local actually he goes to the
crop fields and he has to protect the
vegetables and he shoots all the deer
and whatever else there and then I
managed to get a hold deer for 25 pounds
can I have one
[Laughter]
okay
how long have you been doing the diet so
in April it's four years wow wow do you
have like a before and after yes is it
on your yes wait can you can we pull it
up but I know this is off topic I'm just
like really I'm curious as well there we
go there's a there's a video you'd have
to play the video okay could you play it
I just yeah I just want to be honest
with myself okay honestly okay and I'm
also really excited that vegetables are
bad for you they are so do you like this
one don't get your crutches
about getting the crutches out laughs
do you know what it is right she came
back from America with a load of pills
oh okay right and I said do not take I
don't believe in taking all these
supplements I'd rather you have meat and
two veg oh so it's supplements yes yeah
so yeah yeah yeah you need to be you
don't need supplements I don't take no
supplements so I I actually consider
salt a supplement which is because it's
strange that I saw a lot yeah rice no do
it what do you say do you use that no
bread no carbs is it on your Instagram
yeah
it is because it's a pinned post I like
um Himalayan salt where it says there's
a before and after well I was just like
this it says it says watch me transform
you guys both look young I mean damn I
wouldn't mind having one of them dares
I'm into the dish I've been doing it
about a year I lost weight I have fell
off track a couple of times and I do
cheat but I've I feel better than I've
ever felt so where's the before Oh you
skipped past the before the before is
first yeah blessing what are you doing
it's just perfect come on wow oh wow
so that was during
oh my God you look completely different
you do yeah a lot of butter a lot of
butter
and
actually not much exercising to be
honest but how often do you exercise Oh
there's uh so I used to before
lockdowns I dance sometimes this is
embarrassing oh God
skinny
[Music]
um
sorry when you said supplements are bad
are you referring to all vitamins or
because personally I take creatine and
collagen so were they look you know bad
for me then it depends what collagen and
creatine you're taking but um
from my protein I don't get a specific
one collagen from my protein is very
good oh good yeah it's really clean it's
got nothing in it if you go to other
places they have soy in it and things
you don't want to have soy yeah you want
to avoid soy it affects your estrogen
levels especially in men
um but yeah I got collagen just because
when I lost weight my hair started
falling out because you know your
nutrients go from there to there and so
just wondering how it is you must have
been cutting your calories quite drastic
see for me my weight loss happened
whilst I was eating four to five
thousand calories a day my weight loss
didn't happen by starving myself I
literally eat until I'm bursting
then I eat so I'm bursting then I
started I was writing that I tell Pearl
she doesn't eat enough she needs to eat
three times a day and snack any of my
clients under e don't lose weight yeah
see I was right there
leading me astray with the vegetables
yes she was cheers
for nothing what were the supplements oh
I don't even they're too oh there's some
great big pessary looking things they're
massive America you know Americans I'm
full of rabbits my mom my mom gave it to
me I was like okay I'll try it
but yeah about what you were um saying
about calorie counting just because you
know I am
because you said you were using about
four five thousand regularly over five
thousand well for me
um I had to figure out what my
maintenance calories were
um and I just I started off at 330
pounds which is absolutely insane
thinking about it now
um and gradually you know my calories
went down from you know 3 000
maintenance to 2500 so you know lower
and lower until about 1500 which is too
low for me it's not because um it is
it's too loud and you will do damage
stuff yourself long term
well yeah there's different ways of
doing it I mean not ever sorry I've kind
of overtaken everything but the meat
thing isn't for everyone I think it
would benefit everyone but mentally
people can't do it
um
every client that I coach
reverses all their health issues some of
them my clients go from being completely
bed-bound to then be able to be up and
exercising and doing things this isn't
cutting calories so a lot of my clients
go from 900 calories a day and I
increase it some some of those increase
it to 5000 and they start losing weight
when they're at 900 calories they
stopped you reduce your metabolism when
you do that yeah and then every time
you've got to keep cutting it back and
cutting it back to try and make a little
bit of loss well what you're losing
essentially then when you're under
eating is 50 muscle and 50
um fat so well for me um because I know
it varies with everyone you know weight
loss and health isn't linear which it
would be easier if it was
um but as I've gradually you know lost
the weight because I do this thing
called a body composition obviously
you're into fitness you'll know what it
is
um it's essentially where it it measures
your muscle compared to your fat and
your hydration
um with being on 1500 calories don't get
me wrong you know there are days where I
go over but I pretty comfortably stay on
that and
from my body composition uh my muscle
has gone upwards on the you know graph
and my fat has gone lower for me you
know perhaps you're right perhaps it
will change for me but as someone who's
had issues with food growing up
um I I just want to make sure I can
maintain a healthier weight obviously
I'm not healthy now I've lost
God was it now 122 which is amazing yeah
which is amazing but the the dexa scans
and all those scans are not accurate and
actually if you drink water before you
do one of those scans it will show you a
higher body
um muscle mass I read that I've always
been bad with hydration so nine times
out of ten I've not drank water before
so what I'm saying is they're not
accurate so it's not a it's not a good
way to determine actually calipers are
much more accurate so what I just trust
you think right that
this a
a balanced diet
no problems
no processed foods no processed foods
and the best quality foods that you can
buy yeah I agree I think that's what it
is so that you're gonna buy steak that
either steak and it was massive and it
was really good and it was 30 quid and I
cooked it outside in the garden
because it was that was the instructions
to get to get a skillet and like eat you
really up with loads of butter and it
was all smoking and I like my medium and
that's all I could eat was just the one
steak because there was no room for
anything else but I just think a
balanced diet
and he often that I don't I don't watch
calories I don't watch calories I eat
what I want and um I think grandmas want
to eat more other than you and say more
than most people but not more than ever
I like to eat a lot not rubbish food no
processed stuff I agree with everything
but eating regularly eating regularly is
just gonna spike your insulin
um fat storage hormone that's not a good
thing so if you can eat enough in each
meal to sustain you I so I I eat three
meals a day that's that's fine and I
don't need to eat any more than three
meals a day I'm full up yeah that's
regular three meals a day yeah yeah
that's what I'm saying um so and some
people think you need to eat six times a
day but that's just spiking your insulin
I'm trying to get pill to eat three
times a day yeah you do yeah and I have
a hard time doing three yeah
I was gonna ask what would So based on
like my circumstances as I've said
because I you know gradually gone down
from you know three thousand to about
1500 and when I've because I've actually
gone up to 1700 and I like consistently
gained weight from that
um so you know as someone who is a
trainer what would your like opinion be
if I'm losing consistently I'm not
losing loads at 1500 I'm losing a pound
a week but I'm losing it consistently
okay so first I would say throw away the
scales second I would say you need to do
a reverse diet where you increase the
calories you need to trust the process
you need to allow your body to fire up
again and get everything working you
know when you're starving yourself your
natural ability to know when you're
hungry and know when your fall is
Switched Off
so you need to get all those things in
your body working again
um come out it's not what everybody's
saying well if you we're these women
would they can't have an obese man no
yeah I wouldn't I wouldn't because he is
not taking care of himself he's
unhealthy I mean naturally if you think
back years any animal goes for another
animal mate because they're healthy why
would we go for someone that's not or
what if they didn't know how to be
healthy like say somebody didn't know
how to cook I had to do nothing I'm a
strategist but if I thought he was cute
I'd just feed him less
you can't you can't build a man
no one just wondered like you know no in
general what do you mean obese do you
mean someone who looks particularly
overweight because
certain people are somebody maybe not
actually somebody we need to talk about
the BMI on that skill they're obese on
the BMI
uh so you can get that from a
bodybuilder even that's got no phone
they can be so the the BMI is not a good
but I mean I wouldn't get a bodybuilder
because I think they're too big so
that's what I mean so would you go with
somebody that's
flabby then fat and flabby not built
yeah
she said yeah
you have been the master
yeah
I know they're taking care of them I
know they're on a better journey and
it's not them being sedentary and just
doing for cool I've been now I just I
just wondered have you ever been there
has anybody ever been out with somebody
oh boy other than us
[Laughter]
[Music]
I just wanted because sometimes I find
that the women will not mind the men
taking them and they're fat and
overweight but they won't take them in
when they're fat and overweight
the women that go with the men and say
yeah I'm fat I'm going to lose weight or
they put on weight and they say I want
to lose weight I'm gonna get fat
[Music]
um
that's true
nothing I'm just about to put it out
there
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible